GO TO PREVENT 50 DOT ORG.
>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
WE ARE CONTINUING OUR
DISCUSSION WITH FORMER WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF REINCE
PRIEBUS.
AFTER A TUG-OF-WAR OVER
TARIFFS GARY COHN RESIGNED AND
NOW IT'S WHISPERED LARRY
KUDLOW AN OLD FRIEND MAY TAKE
THE JOB.
HERE HE IS EARLIER THIS MONTH
TO TALK ABOUT THE TRUMP, STEEL
AND ALUMINUM TARIFF.
THERE YOU ARE SO GOOD ON TAX
CUTS.
HE IS SO GOOD ON DEREGULATION,
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I EVEN LIKE HIM ON
IMMIGRATION.
HE HAS NEVER BEEN GOOD ON
TRADE.
IF WE HAVE TO WALK OUT OF
NAFTA OR THE NEGOTIATIONS
TOTALLY BREAKDOWN THIS STEEL
THING TURNS IN FROM A MINOR
IRRITANT TO A MAJOR CALAMITY
FOR THE ECONOMY AND THE STOCK
MARKET.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY HE HAD
TWO CONVERSATIONS WITH LARRY
KUDLOW A FRIEND OF OURS.
WHAT ABOUT THAT?
>> HE IS A GREAT PICK BECAUSE
HE IS THE WORD "TRUMPIAN."
HE IS RESPECTED BY WALL
STREET.
HE ISN'T AFRAID TO PUSH BACK.
THE PRESIDENT RESPECTS HIM.
THOSE ARE GREAT COMBINATIONS.
>> Laura: THE TARIFF
THING --
>> THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T CARE.
HE LOVES GARY COHN AND GARY
HATES THE TARIFFS.
STILL LOVES GARY.
WE ALL DO.
HE LIKES TO HAVE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM THAT DON'T AGREE WITH EACH
OTHER.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD BE BORED
REGARDLESS OF PEOPLE WRITE IN
THE MEDIA ABOUT THE DRAMA AND
THE CHAOS, THE PRESIDENT WOULD
BE BORED IF EVERYONE CAME IN
YOU ARE RIGHT.
DO IT THIS WAY.
>> Laura: THAT IS WHAT THE
MEDIA THINK THAT HE WANTS
YES-MEN.
YOU ARE SO BRAVE.
WE LOVE YOU.
YOU ARE GREAT.
THAT IS THE WRAP ON HIM.
HE WANTS THE CONSTANT PRAISE
AND HE IS ANNOYED THE PEOPLE
DON'T PRAISE HIM.
>> HE DEFINITELY WANTS TO KNOW
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO DECISION
THERE IS NOTHING MAJOR THAT
GET DECIDED -- I CAN ATTEST TO
THIS -- IN THE OVAL OFFICE
THAT IS A NO-BRAIN THING THAT
PEOPLE COME IN AND MAKE A
DECISION.
PEOPLE COME IN, THEY STAND
AROUND HIS DESK.
HE ALLOWED THE ARGUMENT TO
TAKE PLACE.
THEY FIGHT IT OUT.
HE GOES WITH WHATEVER -- NOT
ALWAYS HIS GUT INSTINCTS.
HE BACKS OFF OF THINGS QUITE A
BIT.
BUT WHAT THE MEDIA FOCUSES IN
ON IS THE PROCESS OF THE
ARGUMENT OPPOSE TO THE
THAT IS WHAT I TRY TO REMIND
PEOPLE TO DO.
FOCUS ON THE DECISION.
ISIS.
IN THE COURTS.
TAX CUTS.
REGULATIONS AND EVEN THE
TARIFFS.
PEOPLE WON'T LIKE IT BUT IT'S
A PROCESS THAT INCLUDES
ARGUING AMONG SMART PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF THE PRESIDENT AND HE
GETS IT DONE.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
COMMS DIRECTOR?
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT JOB.
FROM PAT BUCHANAN IN HIS DAY,
FANTASTIC FOR REAGAN.
A HUGE TURNOVER IN THE COMMS
DEPARTMENT.
HOPE HICKS CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
DIDN'T HAVE A HUGE BACKGROUND
IN THE COMMUNICATIONS BUT
TRUSTED.
I HEAR THERE IS SOMEONE SORT
OF CLOSE TO HER WHO MIGHT BE
THOUGHT OF FOR THE JOB.
THEN WE HAVE MERCEDES SCHLAPS
FANTASTIC AND SEASONED.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THIS IS AN ALL-ENCOMPASSING
JOB.
THE PRESS SECRETARY IS A BIG
BUT THE COMMS DIRECTOR DOES
EVERYTHING FROM WORKING WITH
THE PRESS SECRETARY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RAPID RESPONSE
IS IN PLACE, SURROGATES GET
OUT ON THE NETWORKS.
>> EVENTS.
EVENTS WITH THE STEELWORKER.
MERCEDES WORKED ON THAT.
>> ALL THE EVENTS WHETHER IT'S
HARLEY DAVIDSON COMING IN.
>> Laura: GET HIM ON THE
ROAD.
HE IS GREAT ON THE ROAD.
>> RIGHT.
THE COMMS DIRECTOR JOB IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
IT'S ALSO WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHO KNOWS EVERY ARTICLE THAT
IS WRITTEN.
HE WATCHES ALL OF THE KEY
MOMENTS THAT DEFINE THE
NARRATIVE.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN A PERSON
MORE IN TUNE --
>> THEY CRITICIZE HIM FOR
THAT.
YOU WATCH TV.
>> BUT IN REGARD TO THE
COMMUNICATION I DON'T THINK IN
MODERN HISTORY THERE IS A
PRESIDENT THAT CARES MORE
ABOUT WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE READING AND PERCEIVING
THAT IS BEING DONE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT IS NOT TO BE CRITICIZED.
>> Laura: DID HE GO OVER THE
LINE ON THE CHUCK TODD
COMMENT?
>> I WOULDN'T USE THAT
LANGUAGE.
NO.
I THINK CHUCK IS A
PROFESSIONAL.
I HAVE NOTHING BUT PRESS TEXT
TEXT -- BUT RESPECT FOR HIM.
>> Laura: ARE YOU KIDDING
ME?
HAVE YOU SEEN WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT YOU?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT ME EITHER.
>> Laura: HE HAS BEEN
HORRIBLE TO THE PRESIDENT.
HOW IS THAT FAIR AND BALANCED?
>> I WOULD THINK SAYING THOSE
WORDS BRINGS UNWANTED
ATTENTION --
>> Laura: I WOULDN'T USE IT
EITHER.
>> SOMETHING TO AVOID.
>> Laura: IT'S HIS THING.
IT'S HIS THING.
FINALLY ON NORTH KOREA, I KNOW
YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
THIS COULD BE A BIG
BREAKTHROUGH.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE THAT HE IS
MEETING WITH KIM JONG UN.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
HOW DID THE DECISION COME
ABOUT?
>> I THINK THE NARRATIVE ON
THAT GOT OUT OF THE GATE ALL
WRONG.
THE IDEA ON A WHIM THE
PRESIDENT ACCEPTED AN
INVITATION WITHOUT THINKING
ABOUT IT.
AS I UNDERSTANDER IT, THE
SOUTH KOREANS CAME IN THE OVAL
OFFICE THE PRESIDENT HAD
GENERAL MATTIS IN THE OFFICE,
GENERAL McMAST IRIN THE
OFFICE, THE VICE PRESIDENT IN
THE OFFICE.
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CIA.
THE D.N.I. DIRECTOR DAN COATS
IN THE OFFICE AND OTHERS IN
THE OFFICE.
I THINK PEOPLE RUN WITH THE
NARRATIVE AND THEY DON'T
REALIZE THE PRESIDENT ISN'T
MAKING THE DECISIONS IN A
VACUUM.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT I THINK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW.
THIS IS SOMETHING, NEW COMMS
DIRECTOR WOULD CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY.
GET OUT IN FRONT OF THE PEOPLE
SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SURROUNDED BY
REALLY SMART PEOPLE.
THAT TALK AND ARGUE ABOUT
THINGS AND THE DECISIONS ARE
MADE.
INCLUDING WHETHER OR NOT TO
MEET WITH THE NORTH KOREANS.
>> Laura: MERCEDES WOULD
GOOD AT COMM?
NOT THAT I'M PUSHING.